le parisien étant comme c'est un rural
qui s'ignore la présence de quelque 16
cents animaux dans l'enceinte du parc
des expositions ne devait pas le laisser
indifférent le parisien au salon de
l'agriculture un sujet qui passionne les
journalistes depuis des décennies et qui
donne parfois lieu à quelques moqueries
car depuis sa première édition en 1964
le salon international de l'agriculture
à la porte de versailles est le rendez
vous incontournable de nombreux sites à
[Musique]
un petit tour dans les allées du salon
pour caresser de belles bêtes échanger
avec les agriculteurs mais aussi goûté à
quelques spécialités locales
en 1964 des journalistes s'intéressaient
à ces goûteurs amateurs
monsieur au bout de la troisième ou
quatrième dégustation est ce que votre
palais toujours aussi sensible je leur
fais nous avons ce qu'il faut intéresser
et embrun pique assiette une caricature
du visiteur parisien qui s'installe dès
le début du salon en 1975 ce journaliste
en remettait une couche
pour lui si le parisien se rendait au
salon c'était avant tout pour préparer
ses vacances le parisien s'informent
déguste il note des abres il commande
parfois et souvent pensante aux
prochaines vacances il demande la liste
des gîtes ruraux des hôtels de campagne
des spéciales
un portrait peu flatteur auquel
n'échappe est passé jeunes parisiens en
visite sur le salon quelques années plus
tôt le salon de l'agriculture on le sait
pas assez est aussi celui des enfants
des petits-enfants de paris qui ne
connaissent guère les choses de la
nature les pauvres qu à travers ce qu'on
leur ont dit dans les livres
et ça qu'est ce que ça fait un mouton
non ça c'est un chien dans les années 90
si le commentaire c'est un peu édulcoré
encore une fois le parisien au salon de
l'agriculture n'échappait pas aux
journalistes
quand on est né que l'on a grandi à
paris tout semble très surprenant au
salon d'agriculture ils sont tous très
impressionnés iops et les odeurs et
impressionne aussi des choses
ils n'ont pas l'habitude d'en région
parisienne la première chose qu'ils ont
dit oulala ce que ça seront pas bons
aujourd'hui malgré l'odeur pour certains
l'ambiance du salon de l'agriculture
attire toujours autant les citadins en
2018 sur les quelque six cent soixante
douze mille visiteurs 61% et est
francilien
[Musique]